This morning
my toddlers woke up with a cough and a little bit of a sore throat,
and I don't usually keep cough drops or traditional
medicine in the house,
so let's make some.
Wanted to make lemon,
ginger, and elderberry cough drops.
I poured some honey into my pot and then moved on to peeling my ginger.
Didn't wanna use too much ginger
cause I didn't want it to be too spicy for them,
so I just eyeballed it
and then also added some elderberry and about half a lemon.
You can definitely adjust this to whatever you wanna do.
After I added all my ingredients to my honey,
I gave it a good stir
and boiled it on the stove
until it reached about 300 degrees Fahrenheit.
In the meantime, I prepped my mold.
Since my honey was hot enough and reached the hard crack stage,
I spooned it into my mold.
I had to work quickly because towards the end
my honey began to thicken.
Pop those in the fridge to harden quicker
and then when they were cooled off,
pop them out of their molds.
I laid them on some aero root powder to prevent them from sticking,
but you can also use cornstarch or powdered sugar.
These were so soothing.